for the past five years there has been a
wii sports sized hole in the nintendo
switch's library a lot has changed since
that game's monumental success 16 years
ago not only has my teenage angst
fizzled out but so has the trend of
motion control in games some things
should just stay in the past and one can
make the case that motion controlled
sports games are among them thankfully
that isn't the case and if anything
nintendo switch sports makes a strong
case for why not because its motion
controls are as revelatory as the
original but because the same sense of
brazen fun that came from playing wii
sports with a good group of friends or
family is as potent as ever in its
successor on the court of modern day
video games switch sports makes some
perplexing steps along the way but
ultimately puts on a worthy performance
[Music]
nintendo switch sports is at its core
the same as wii sports was all those
years ago a game in which you swing your
arms around and reenact a sport if your
wii sports and wii sports resort veteran
the feeling of tennis bowling or
chumbara will be second nature even with
the addition of new sports like
volleyball and soccer there's very
little innovation in what switch sports
attempts to do and i think that's a good
thing
the game doesn't feel like it's trying
to revitalize a trend instead it
recaptures the simplicity of the
original and in doing so rekindles the
same magic it's straightforward
unadulterated and above all approachable
five to six sports are played by holding
a joycon in one hand as the avatars move
independently on screen for you with the
exception being soccer which uses two
joy cons whether you're swinging a
racket throwing a bowling ball or
striking a sword playing the sport is as
simple as swinging your arm so of course
i wrangled up three friends of the
office handed them joy-cons and jumped
into each sport
of the six sports four are absolute
winners badminton is a vigorous back and
forth battle to catch the other avatar
off balance it utilizes the joy-con's
gyro tracking which allows for more
specific strikes including a drop shot
maneuver that if time right can cause
your opponent's avatar to fumble and
fall to the ground some matches were
long and vigorous causing me to break a
sweat and leaving my arms sore the
following day making it a fun and
rigorous workout if you really get into
it
in chambara two players stand in a ring
suspended in the air with the goal of
knocking their opponent off a ledge
through sword-based combat chimbara
features three different weapons single
sword charge sword and twin swords
single sword offers the most basic form
of block and attack charge swords has a
power level that increases with every
successful block and when used at the
right time can unleash a powerful blow
and twin swords which requires the
player to use both joy-cons gives the
player the ability to block with one
sword while setting up a strike with the
other chimbara duels were often slow and
methodical i focus on reading my
opponent's movements to figure out where
to block and acting in the moment of
opportunity to attack suffice to say it
made me feel like a total sword swinging
cool dude despite how silly i knew i
actually looked but that's a part of the
magic i undoubtedly look like an idiot
the entire time but i felt cool and was
having fun sadly nintendo switched
sports is missing boxing a staple of the
original but chambara is a suitable
replacement and one that feels more
deliberate and satisfying than boxing's
arm flailing zaniness for tennis
nintendo switch sports takes the if it
ain't broke don't fix it approach and
i'm glad this is the case joycon in hand
the moment a tennis match started all
the muscle memory and timing from the
wii sports days returned to me
the same natural joyous feeling flooded
back this time tinged with nostalgia the
improvement for the switch version of
tennis comes from the additional
accuracy afforded by the joy-con
smacking the ball with a twist of the
wrist and seeing it spin to the other
side of the court just felt great then
there's the premier nintendo switch
sports activity
bowling it's hard to imagine bowling
being any better than in previous wii
sports iterations but nintendo switch
sports improves the experience by adding
simultaneous mode instead of taking
turns bowling one by one all players can
now bowl at the same time either solo or
on teams and the result
is just ridiculously fun
instead of bowling one after the other i
got to collectively enjoy the chaos of
attempting the same frame together and
react alongside my friends in real time
it just felt great
additionally bowling now features a
special mode which tasks the player with
having to navigate their ball down an
obstacle ridden bowling lane pair that
with having multiple bowlers launching
bowling ball simultaneously and
hilarious antics ensue there was one
moment when i curved a bowling ball
around a difficult obstacle and landed a
strike as my opponents watched in dismay
my teammate and i howled and high-fived
unable to contain our excitement at the
feet it's moments like this that inspire
a sense of camaraderie and serve as the
strongest reminder of why it's important
to have a wii sports-like experience on
the switch i hadn't felt that kind of
joy that comes from playing these games
with other people in a long time and
it's a sensation i sorely missed but not
all sports stick the landing volleyball
specifically is the least intuitive of
all the sports to pick up and play as it
requires learning a series of movements
opposed to just swinging your arm
introducing it to a group of three new
players and having them understand the
moves and when to use them was
cumbersome it felt like a speed bump
teaching players the specific timing and
stances involved compared to the pick up
and play simplicity of all the other
games additionally when playing with
multiple people locally the sport is
presented as a 4-way split screen even
on a 60-inch tv the split made picking
out the necessary details feel a bit
strenuous like seeing the ball or
reading where your character and what
move to perform next that a company was
standing shoulder to shoulder with three
other people made the whole scenario
feel a little too snug there's much less
opportunity to cut loose than with other
sports another issue is that the
specific volleyball moves needed to play
the game are timed according to the
on-screen avatar's often oddly slow and
floaty movements which means playing
never feels intuitive or natural and
getting into a flow or rhythm as you can
with other sports is difficult still we
had some fun but i can't be confident
that everyone knew what they were doing
and often felt deflating to hop into
volleyball after a game of tennis or
bowling
of all the sports soccer is the oddest
of the bunch it features the most
intricate controls and is more like a
traditional sports game
in the 1v1 or 4v4 modes two joycons are
required for each player so they can
have full control over moving the avatar
around the field while also having
buttons for sprinting and jumping in
order to kick the ball players have to
swing either controller in the direction
they want to kick it this all sounds
great on paper but playing feels
unnaturally slow and tedious whether i
was playing against an ai opponent or
another human player the result was slow
and unsatisfying soccer feels like a
sport added to nintendo switch sports
specifically for competitive online play
which was unavailable at the time of
this review and it's a nice suggestion
for those looking for that kind of
experience but until i can actually play
it online i have no way of knowing
whether it succeeds in what it's trying
to do
then there's shootout a soccer mode that
requires the ring fit leg strap
accessory which comes bundled with the
physical purchase of nintendo switch
sports
this mode tasks the player with kicking
a soccer ball into the net and that's it
the mode feels rather undercooked
shoehorned into warrant the inclusion of
an accessory that added little value to
my experience
nintendo has said it has plans on adding
leg strap kicking functionality to the
regular soccer mode but as it stands
shootout is a complete miss if you buy
the game digitally and don't have the
leg strap be assured that you're not
missing anything at the moment it's
cheesy to say but just like the nature
of real sports there were many genuine
surprises unexpected comebacks woeful
defeats and triumphant victories to be
found in switch sports and these moments
can only be really felt when playing
with others
playing this game alone however
is a different much less appealing
experience owing to the glaring absence
of a progress tracker and training mode
in the original wii sports trading mode
is a collection of mini games and
challenges designed to improve your
skills presenting you with tasks like
hitting a tennis ball consecutively or
knocking out a series of punching bags
under a stressful countdown in boxing
they were a ton of fun and a welcome
change of pace for those wanting to play
solo but i was taken aback to see
trading modes missing in nintendo switch
sports even wii sports club the wii
sports hd remake for the wii u and wii
sports resort featured equivalent
challenge modes the closest nintendo
switch sports gets is bowling's special
mode which is like the original wii
sports as bowling challenges the lack of
similar modes for other sports feels
like a big blunder especially for those
looking to play offline while i would
happily play the previous wii sports
titles alone for extended periods of
time it wasn't long until i grew tired
of playing nintendo switch sports by
myself
there's only so much gratification in
competing against ai controlled
opponents over and over again even when
set at harder difficulties it quickly
began feeling repetitive worsening the
issue is the lack of a progress tracker
if playing nintendo switch sports with
others as a joyous communial experience
playing alone is a depressing isolating
one out of the box the customization
choices leave a lot to be desired and
felt pretty bare bones thankfully i was
relieved to use my me in place of the
game's newly designed characters however
if a friend wants to use their own me it
can be a bit of a hassle unless the
other player already has an account on
your switch if not they'll have to make
one in order to create and use a me
which just seems like an unnecessary
obstacle now i don't anticipate that
being a major concern for many new
players it was just a minor letdown for
me as someone looking to scratch that
itch of nostalgia the only way to unlock
items and cosmetics is by playing
against real players in switch sports as
online mode with no way to unlock
customizable objects like hats masks
skins for your equipment or even glasses
in offline mode i was left with a measly
selection of options to express myself
since online functionality was
unavailable during the review process i
wasn't able to experience all of what
nintendo switch sports has to offer the
last major court comes in playing
nintendo switch sports in tabletop mode
if you're thinking of taking the game on
the go keep in mind you'll want to bring
a dock at all of your chords if you want
to play with other people because
tabletop mode only works with a single
player either that or be prepared to
trade the joy cons back and forth which
may certainly be a buzzkill considering
the games at its best when playing with
others at the same time considering the
screen size and switch sports being a
physically active game to play i can
understand the design choice though
after all these years it's easy to
associate wii sports most with its
popularization of motion controls and
games but its greatest achievement may
actually be that even after 16 years its
core gameplay design is a potent
reminder how much fun simple games with
friends can be
i didn't realize how much i needed a wii
sports like experience in my life until
playing nintendo switch sports playing
by myself for an extended period of time
was boring and monotonous and the
absence of certain single player modes
is a major oversight but nintendo switch
sports is a fantastic multiplayer game
that for the most part invites anyone
and everyone to pick up a controller and
flail their limbs about it has its
issues but they fall away when you have
other people to play with and are
joyously going toe-to-toe in virtual
sports as with the original wii sports
nintendo switch sports finds a beauty
and fun and simplicity and bowling is
great it's better than real lifeboard
[Music]
damn jordan
yes
they were ahead of us at like 20 points
so we're like not
we're not catching up